.
>>> DONALD TRUMP FORMER ATTORNEY
MICHAEL COHEN MAKING THE SECOND
APPEARANCE TOMORROW BEFORE A NEW
YORK GRAND JURY, KEY WITNESS IN
CASE INVESTIGATING A HUSH MONEY
PAYMENT TO ADULT FILM STAR
STORMY DANIELS THE PAYMENT MADE
DAYS BEFORE THE 2016 ELECTION.
PROSECUTORS HANDLING THE CASE
ARE SIGNALLING THAT A CRIMINAL
INDICTMENT FOR TRUMP COULD BE
COMING SOON, FORMER PRESIDENT
SLAMMING THIS CASE FUND-RAISING
E-MAIL TODAY SAYING PROSECUTORS
ARE TRYING TO QUOTE DESTROY OUR
MAGA MOVEMENT.
AND HIS ATTORNEY IS CLAIMING
TRUMP HIMSELF IS THE VICTIM IN
THIS CASE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP DENIED FROM
DAY ONE HAVING ANY FAIR WITH
THIS WOMAN, SHE CAME OUT BEFORE
THE ELECTION AND SAID UNLESS YOU
PAY ME, I'M GOING TO MAKE A
PUBLIC STORY ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT HE SAYS IS COMPLETELY
UNTRUE.
>> UP FRONT THE FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE LAWYER TY COBB, WE
TALKED SO MUCH ABOUT ALL OF THE
LEGAL TROUBLES THAT THE POSSIBLE
INDICTMENTS THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT MAY BE FACING.
AS YOU SEE TRUMP AND HIS LAWYER
THERE RAMPING UP PUBLIC ATTACKS
ON THIS SPECIFIC CASE, WHERE DO
YOU THINK WE ARE?
DO YOU THINK AN INDICTMENT IS
IMMINENT FOR DONALD TRUMP HERE?
>> I DO THINK AN INDICTMENT IS
IMMINENT BASED ON THE RECENT
REPORTING AND THE GRAND JURY
ACTIVITY.
I'M NOT SURE THIS IS THE BEST
CASE TO LEAD WITH.
I'M NOT SURE IT WILL HAVE THAT
GREAT AN IMPACT ON HIM.
BUT YES, I DO, I DO HEAR THE
PRESIDENT AND JOE TALKING ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT AS THE ALLEGED
VICTIM HERE, AND THAT'S --
THAT'S TRUMP AT HIS BEST.
>> YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, HE
DIDN'T TESTIFY BEFORE THE GRAND
JURY, IF INDICTED HE WILL HAVE
TO APPEAR IN COURT.
BUT WOULD YOU, DO YOU THINK THAT
WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
HIM NOT TO APPEAR BEFORE THIS
GRAND JURY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, ANY FIRST YEAR
LAW STUDENT CRIMINAL PRACTICE
WOULD -- WOULD ADVISE THE
PRESIDENT NOT TO SHOW UP IN
FRONT OF A GRAND JURY
PARTICULARLY IN THE CASE WHERE
THE PROOF PROBLEMS THAT THE
PROSECUTION HAS YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE NOT OVERWHELMING BUT
THEY'RE -- THERE ARE PROBLEMS IN
TERMS OF HOW THIS CASE WILL BE
PRESENTED TO A JURY.
>> SO JUST TO BE CLEAR, NONE OF
THIS IS DETERRING TRUMP FROM
RUNNING FOR REELECTION, IN FACT,
SEEMS TO BE ENCOURAGING HIM, IF
HE GETS BACK IN OFFICE HE WOULD
BE IMMUNE TO ANY OF THESE
INDICTMENTS END UP WITH
CONVICTIONS.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID IN WHY LAST
NIGHT
>> WE STAND UP TO THE CROOKED
DEMOCRAT PROSECUTORS ALL
OVERTIME COUNTRY, IF I FLY OVER
STATE THAT HAPPENS TO BE
DEMOCRATIC, LET'S CALL THEM INTO
A GRAND JURY, THEY HAVE NEVER
NOBODY HAS EVER WEAPONIZED LIKE
THIS GROUP OF PEOPLE.
THEY'RE MANIACS.
>> YOU KNOW HIM WELL.
YOU KNOW HOW HE HANDLES THESE
SORTS OF YOU KNOW, SITUATIONS.
DO YOU THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT WOULD STOP HIM FROM RUNNING
LEGALLY?
I GUESS ALSO SEPARATE FROM THAT,
TY, DOES THIS GIVE HIM OXYGEN?
>> SO THOSE ARE IF QUESTIONS, I
WILL SAY THAT THAT TAPE CUTS
SORT OF RIGHT OUT OF THE DSM 5
ON NARCISSIM.
WE'LL HEAR A LOT OF THAT IF HE
IS CHARGED.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS CASE
OR EVEN THE GEORGIA CASE HOWEVER
THAT TURNS OUT WHETHER CHARGES
ARE BROUGHT, WHETHER THEY
INCLUDE HIM, WILL DETER HIM FROM
HIS RUN.
I'M NOT SURE EITHER WOULD HAVE A
LOT OF IMPACT AS THE, AS THE
CONSEQUENCES CERTAINLY THE NEW
YORK CASE, WHILE A LITTLE BIT
HARD TO ESTIMATE DON'T APPEAR TO
BE VERY SERIOUS I THINK IT'S
HIGHLY UNLIKELY, YOU KNOW, HE
COULD GO TO JAIL IN CONNECTION
WITH CONTEMPLATED CHARGES IN NEW
YORK.
I DO THINK WHEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT COMES FORWARD WITH
WHAT I BELIEVE WILL BE AN
INDICTMENT OVER THE INSTRUCTION
OF THE JANUARY 6 PROCEEDING
INVOLVING VICE PRESIDENT PENCE
AND QUITE LIKELY DEFRAUDING THE
UNITED STATES CHARGE AS WELL, I
DO THINK THAT WILL HAVE
POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES FOR HIM.
IT WILL FREEZE HIS DONORS.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE MANY
PASSIONATE SUPPORTERS OUT THERE
AND PEOPLE WILLING TO RIDE WITH
HIM FOR AWHILE.
BUT AT THAT POINT, HE'LL BE
ASKING FOR SO MUCH MONEY THAT
THEY WILL BE A LOT OF CHECKS AND
BALANCES ON THE DONOR SIDE I
THINK WILL HALT HIS ABILITY TO
RAISE FUNDS.
>> WELL, TY COBB THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, THAT'S INTERESTING AS YOU
POINT OUT IT'S THE POLITIC